This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When reporter Julie Bluesset got on a plane to Hong Kong in November of last year, she thought she was going to cover the aftermath of a disaster. Julie is a China correspondent for the Dutch newspaper De Volksgrant. I'd seen the images on the news the evening before. Seven huge residential towers in the Tai Po neighborhood of Hong Kong completely engulfed in flames. By the time I landed, 20 hours had passed.
这里是“99%隐形”（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。去年11月，当记者朱莉·布吕塞（Julie Bluesset）搭乘飞机前往香港时，她以为自己是去报道一场灾难过后的景象。朱莉是荷兰《人民报》（De Volksgrant）的中国驻地记者。前一天晚上，我在新闻上看到了那些画面。香港大埔区有七栋巨大的住宅大楼完全被大火吞噬。等我落地时，已经过去20个小时了。
I figured the fire would be out, and I'd be documenting the wreckage, talking to survivors. But that's not what she found. When I got there, the buildings, all part of this complex called Wang Fook Court, were still burning, not smoldering, but burning. Seven towers, 32 stories each, and still on fire. Still billowing smoke. There's, I guess there's one or two towers that are... completely blackened, and then there's a few that are just filled with smoke. It's kind of insane.
我想火应该已经灭了，而我会去记录残骸并采访幸存者。但她看到的并非如此。当我到达那里时，那些建筑——都属于一个叫宏福苑（Wang Fook Court）的小区——还在燃烧，不是在冒烟，而是在燃烧。七栋大楼，每栋32层，依然在着火。依然在滚滚冒烟。我想，有一两栋大楼已经……完全被烧黑了，还有几栋则满是浓烟。简直疯狂。
And every so often, you'd hear it before you saw it. These explosions or banging sounds coming from somewhere deep inside the towers. I was talking about it with my friend Jones. She was helping me translate from Cantonese that day. They suspect it is a bathroom or kitchen. Maybe. Yeah. Or maybe gas?
而且每隔一段时间，你都是先听到声音，然后才看到。那些爆炸声或撞击声来自大楼内部的某个深处。我当时正和我的朋友琼斯（Jones）讨论这事。那天她帮我从粤语翻译。他们怀疑那是浴室或厨房。也许吧。是的。或者可能是燃气？
And then the friend is quite serious. Getting serious right now. Julie was standing in a park just across the way from the burning complex. And all around her were people from the neighborhood. There was this 73-year-old guy called Ma Ming, a local, who'd been at the park when the fire broke out the day before. He'd seen it start. He told me the flames just raced up those 32 floors.
然后这位朋友变得非常严肃。现在开始变得严肃了。朱莉当时正站在正对火灾小区的公园里。她周围全都是附近的居民。有一个名叫马明（Ma Ming）的73岁当地大爷，前一天火灾爆发时他就在公园里。他目睹了火灾的发生。他告诉我，火势顺着那32层楼直窜而上。
And within 20 minutes, the firefighters had completely lost control. And I asked him, because this was already the narrative that was forming in the news. I'd read it on my phone on the way to the airport that morning. I asked him, was it the bamboo? The eight towers at Taipo had been undergoing renovation, and all seven that were on fire were wrapped from top to bottom in bamboo scaffolding. In the immediate wake of the inferno, bamboo was the most obvious culprit. It's breaking news from Hong Kong where a massive fire has engulfed a housing complex.
在短短20分钟内，消防员就完全失去了控制。我问了他这个问题，因为当时新闻中已经开始出现这种说法。那天早上在去机场的路上，我在手机上读到了。我问他，是竹子的问题吗？大埔的那八栋大楼当时正在进行翻新，而着火的七栋大楼从头到脚都包裹着竹脚手架。在大火发生后的第一时间，竹子成了最显眼的罪魁祸首。这是来自香港的突发新闻，一场大火吞噬了一个住宅小区。
Bamboo scaffolding fixed on the outside of the towers is fueling the blaze. The fire spread quickly due to bamboo scaffolding and highly flammable. The housing complex was covered in scaffolding made from bamboo, which appears to have helped the fire spread. Combustible scaffolding should be prohibited period. I mean, we shouldn't use bamboo. This is an unnecessary risk for a catastrophic fire. But Ma was adamant in his answer. He said, no, it wasn't because of the bamboo that the fire spread so quickly.
固定在大楼外侧的竹脚手架助长了火势。由于竹脚手架高度易燃，火势迅速蔓延。该住宅小区覆盖着用竹子制作的脚手架，这似乎导致了火势的蔓延。可燃脚手架必须彻底禁止。我的意思是，我们不应该使用竹子。这是引发灾难性火灾的不必要风险。但马明在回答时非常坚决。他说，不对，火势蔓延得这么快并不是因为竹子。
That's not, that's going to so fast. He insisted it was because of the plastic netting that had been draped around the bamboo. That's what caught. Mr. Ma, I think they are nylon, the polyester fabrics, so that makes the fire quickly spread out. For someone who isn't from Hong Kong, our discussion at that moment might have appeared strange. maybe even insensitive. The buildings were still burning behind us. Nearly 300 people were still unaccounted for.
那不是，那个着火太快了。他坚信是因为缠绕在竹子周围的塑料网。那是着火的东西。马先生，我认为它们是尼龙，是聚酯纤维织物，所以这使得火势迅速蔓延开来。对于一个并非来自香港的人来说，我们当时的讨论在当时看来可能会显得有些奇怪。甚至可能有些不近人情。我们身后的建筑物还在燃烧。将近300人仍然下落不明。
And here we were distinguishing between construction materials. Only that distinction, bamboo versus netting, would turn out to matter enormously. Because bamboo scaffolding is a tradition that has long helped set this city apart from the Chinese mainland. But now the fire at Wangfuk Court might just spell the end of bamboo scaffolding in Hong Kong. If you've ever seen any images of Hong Kong, you've seen its bamboo.
而我们却在这里分辨建筑材料。唯独这种区分——竹子与网子——结果却至关重要。因为竹脚手架是一项长期以来让这座城市区别于中国内地的传统。但现在，宏福苑的大火可能正宣告着香港竹脚手架时代的终结。如果你见过任何香港的影像，你就见过它的竹子。
It's just as iconic as Hong Kong's fairies, dim sum restaurants, skyscrapers, and neon signs. The omnipresent use of bamboo scaffolding for construction or renovation jobs. In Hong Kong, entire skyscrapers are often fully encased in bamboo scaffolding. On any given day, countless stocks of bamboo cover dozens of glass office buildings from top to bottom. enveloping the city's skyline like a veil. It's really hard to overstate how much bamboo is part of Hong Kong's image and identity. In tourist shops, I even found these little plastic miniatures of Hong Kong buildings, and they all included bamboo scaffolding.
它和香港的渡轮、点心茶楼、摩天大楼以及霓虹灯招牌一样具有标志性。在建筑或翻新工程中，无处不在地使用竹脚手架。在香港，整座摩天大楼通常都被完全包裹在竹脚手架中。在任何特定的一天里，无数的竹竿从上到下覆盖着数十栋玻璃办公楼，像面纱一样笼罩着城市的天际线。很难过分夸大竹子在香港形象和身份认同中所占的比重。在旅游商店里，我甚至找到了这些香港建筑的小塑料微缩模型，它们无一例外都包含了竹脚手架。
And for those who haven't had the chance to go to Hong Kong, there's always this vital action scene in Rush Hour 2 with Jackie Chan and Chris Tucker. The scene hinges on a stunt in which Chan and Tucker maneuver across the bamboo scaffolding the side of a building. And they end up hanging from this one really tall piece of bamboo, which just bends and bends and bends. Don't worry. Chinese bamboo is very stone.
而对于那些没有机会去香港的人来说，《尖峰时刻2》（Rush Hour 2）中成龙和克里斯·塔克（Chris Tucker）那段至关重要的动作戏总是会上演。这场戏的核心是一个特技：成龙和塔克在一栋建筑侧面的竹脚手架上穿梭。他们最终挂在了一根非常高的竹子上，那根竹子不停地弯曲、弯曲、再弯曲。别担心。中国竹子非常硬。
I'm sure. Until finally, it breaks. Because, you know, it's a comedy. You won't see anywhere near this much bamboo in the rest of China. Today, on China's mainland, including where I live in Beijing, scaffolding is made out of metal, not bamboo. Other places in China might have their own vernacular building styles, but only in Hong Kong is the site of construction and maintenance itself,
我确信。直到最后，它断了。因为，你知道的，这是一部喜剧。在中国其他地方，你绝对看不到这么多的竹子。如今，在中国内地，包括我居住的北京，脚手架都是用金属做的，而不是竹子。中国其他地方可能有他们自己本土的建筑风格，但唯独在香港，建筑和维护的场景本身，
part of the vernacular identity. Perhaps no city on earth more proudly displays its own upkeep. Therefore, I say the bamboo scaffold is just like grow together with Hong Kong. This is low, an engineer with over 30 years of experience in Hong Kong's construction industry. He asked me not to use his full name. And Lowe thinks the tradition of bamboo scaffolding hasn't survived here simply by accident. Hong Kong, he says, was by necessity built with bamboo. Hong Kong is a place. We don't have much flat land.
成为了本土身份认同的一部分。或许地球上没有哪座城市能像香港这样，如此自豪地展示自身的修缮过程。因此，我可以说竹脚手架就像是和香港一起生长的。这是罗（Lowe），一位在香港建筑行业拥有30多年经验的工程师。他要求我不要使用他的全名。罗认为，竹脚手架这一传统在这里能够延续下来绝非偶然。他说，香港是出于必要才用竹子建造的。香港是一个这样的地方。我们没有多少平地。
It's quite a lot of mountain hill. And you can see Hong Kong Island. Most of the ground is sloping. But the premium on usable land, Hong Kong is extraordinarily dense. Its streets are narrow. Its alleys narrower. Construction and repair work in these spaces is notoriously tricky, requiring constant adaptation. Therefore, we try to use some, what can I describe, some very flexible, easy to mobilize solution for the problem. This is all the benefit of bamboo scaffold. Bamboo is far lighter than steel.
这里有很多山丘。你可以看到香港岛。大部分地面都是倾斜的。但由于可用土地极其宝贵，香港的人口密度异常之高。它的街道很窄。它的巷子更窄。在这些空间里的施工和修缮工作出了名地棘手，需要不断地调整。因此，我们尝试使用一些，我该怎么形容呢，一些非常灵活、易于调配的解决方案来解决问题。这全都是竹脚手架的好处。竹子比钢材轻得多。
It's even lighter than wood. It's actually a grass. so it can be easily carried and assembled by hand. And there's no standard size. You can quickly cut it down to suit whatever space it needs to fit. The result is that this ancient construction material is still useful, maybe even perfect, for modern, crowded Hong Kong. There's a line from a bamboo scaffolding master that sums it up perfectly,
它甚至比木头还要轻。它实际上是一种草。因此可以由人工轻松搬运和组装。而且没有标准尺寸。你可以迅速将它砍短，以适应它需要契合的任何空间。结果就是，这种古老的建筑材料对于现代拥挤的香港而言依然非常有用，甚至可以说是完美的。有一句出自竹脚手架老师傅的话完美地总结了这一点，
wherever a person fits. A bamboo scaffold fits. And for something as straight as bamboo, you'd be surprised how many shapes can be made out of it. Walk around Hong Kong and you'll see lopsided bamboo pyramids surrounding movie marquise and long bamboo tendrils snaking around windows. And then there's this. Bambo scaffolding doesn't need to be anchored to the ground or descend from the roof of a structure with a crane. Instead, the 65th floor of an office building is often the starting place for a typical bamboo platform.
人能呆的地方。竹脚手架就能搭。对于像竹子这样直挺挺的东西，你可能会惊讶于能用它做出多少种形状。在香港四处走走，你会看到倾斜的竹金字塔环绕着电影院的招牌，长长的竹藤在窗户周围盘绕。还有这个。竹脚手架不需要锚固在地面上，也不需要用起重机从建筑物的屋顶吊下来。相反，办公大楼的第65层通常是典型竹平台的起点。
Most of the time, it just shoots straight out of the window with nothing but air underneath it. From there, two scaffolders working alone can quickly build the bamboo out in any shape and direction that's required for the job, all without ever for a second touching the ground or blocking traffic. Heavy metal scaffolding, by contrast, usually needs to be built from the ground up. It comes in fixed tube lengths and requires clamps, platforms, and standardized components. On a flat surface in an open space, it's fast and it's cheap. But in a narrow alley on a curved facade, on the side of a 64-story tower on a Hong Kong hillside, steel becomes slow and expensive. And bamboo scaffolding isn't just practical for patching up a building or making repairs.
大多数时候，它只是直接从窗户向外延伸，下方除了空气什么都没有。从那里开始，两名单独作业的脚手架工人可以迅速将竹子向工作所需的任何形状和方向延伸，全程甚至不需要有一秒钟触及地面或阻挡交通。相比之下，重型金属脚手架通常需要从地面向上搭建。它具有固定的管长，并需要夹具、平台和标准化的部件。在开阔空间的平坦地面上，它又快又便宜。但在狭窄的小巷里、在弧形的外墙上、在香港山坡上64层高的建筑侧面，钢材就会变得既缓慢又昂贵。而且竹脚手架不仅对修补建筑或进行修理很实用。
It's often the way skyscrapers are constructed in Hong Kong. Hong Kong is famous for its daring and surreal architecture. And Lowe believes that's because bamboo has made it easier for construction firms here to pursue ambitious designs more often. He says bamboo scaffolding is so easy to manipulate that it can be moulded alongside any shape an architect requires. Just like a tailor, because every time the angle of the scaffold perfectly matched with the building shape,
它通常也是香港摩天大楼的建造方式。香港以其大胆而超现实的建筑风格而闻名。罗认为，这是因为竹子让这里的建筑公司能够更频繁地追求雄心勃勃的设计。他说竹脚手架极易塑形，可以根据建筑师要求的任何形状进行塑造。就像裁缝一样，因为每次脚手架的角度都能与建筑物的形状完美契合，
and if no choice, we have to use metal scaffold, then maybe we need to use one or two months or more time for preparations. Because everything is heavy by three or four times or more. Bamboo scaffolders usually require far less prep. Instead, most of the time, they just show up, eyeball the situation, and get to work. Hey, good morning. Good morning.
如果没有选择，我们不得不使用金属脚手架，那可能我们需要用一到两个月或更多的时间来做准备。因为每一样东西都重了三四倍甚至更多。竹脚手架工人通常需要少得多的准备工作。相反，大多数情况下，他们只是出现，目测一下情况，然后就开始干活。嘿，早安。早安。
Almost in place. On a recent hot, humid day in Hong Kong, I watched one such scene play out from a tiny alley in the Prince Edward neighborhood, next to two dim sum restaurants, the Jade and the Pearl. The alley couldn't have been more than three meters wide, flanked on both sides by tall residential buildings. Two bamboo scaffolders, Timmy Soh and his father, Sotifai, were gathering materials from the truck. Timmy briefed me on the job. So that one will be the building. We're working at the orange color one. But we can walk around to see all the pipes where they are. And we're working at the 14th floor. The assignment that day was to build a bamboo balcony that could reach
差不多到位了。在香港一个炎热潮湿的日子里，我从太子（Prince Edward）社区的一条极窄小巷里，看着这样一幕上演，巷子紧邻着两家点心茶楼——翡翠（Jade）和珍珠（Pearl）。这条巷子最多也就三米宽，两侧都是高耸的住宅楼。两名竹脚手架工人——蒂米·索（Timmy Soh）和他的父亲索蒂法（Sotifai）——正在卡车旁收集材料。蒂米向我简要介绍了这项工作。所以那个将是建筑物。我们在那个橙色颜色的地方工作。但我们可以走过去看看所有管道都在哪里。我们在第14层工作。那天的工作任务是搭建一个能够触及
an air conditioning unit on the side of one of the buildings. This is probably the same most common job scaffolders are asked to do here. Modern Hong Kong is nothing without its air conditioning. But Hong Kong's AC units are not the dinky one-off window units that you see in a lot of American apartments. They're usually located away from windows in hard-to-reach places, crammed alongside a complicated maze of pipes and fixtures for plumbing, electricity, internet, everything. And this building was no different. But Timmy assured me they'd make quick work of it. You already came here before or is that what's happening now? No, it's happening now. This is the first time I've been here.
其中一栋建筑侧面空调机组的竹阳台。这可能也是工人们在这里被要求做的最常见的工作。现代香港离不开空调。但香港的空调可不是你在很多美国公寓里看到的那种小型单窗式空调。它们通常位于远离窗户、难以触及的地方，与管道、电力、互联网等各种复杂交错的管线和装置挤在一起。这栋建筑也不例外。但蒂米向我保证，他们会很快搞定。你之前已经来过这里了，还是说这就是现在的情况？不，就是现在的情况。这是我第一次来这里。
All their equipment seemed custom made for Hong Kong. They had this tiny cart designed to slot exactly inside a standard Hong Kong elevator with just enough space on the side for two scaffolders. And on top of it, all their gear alongside bundles of bamboo. Ooh, oh, it fits perfectly. Yes, everything are designed by ourselves. So it fits most of the environment in Hong Kong. You just asked someone to make it precisely according to your own dimensions?
他们所有的设备似乎都是为香港量身定制的。他们有一个极小的手推车，设计得正好可以塞进香港的标准电梯里，旁边刚好有足够的空间容纳两名脚手架工人。在手推车上方，是他们所有的装备以及成捆的竹子。噢，哦，完美契合。是的，所有东西都是我们自己设计的。所以它适合香港绝大多数的环境。你是找人严格按照你们自己的尺寸定制的吗？
Actually, my father made it by himself. So it's all unique design. The elevator only went to the 13th floor. They carried their supplies to the next floor themselves. No problem. They picked up the bamboo poles and walked up the stairs as if they weighed nothing. Which, compared to steel, they basically do. In which surely counts as one of the great disappointments of my life,
其实是我父亲自己做的。所以这全是独特的设计。电梯只到13楼。他们自己把物资扛到了下一楼层。没问题。他们拿起竹竿，走上楼梯，仿佛它们毫无重量。与钢材相比，它们确实基本上没什么重量。这绝对堪称我人生中的一大憾事，
safety regulations prohibited me from going out onto the scaffolding with them. So I went back down, to gock at them from the alley. We stayed in touch by Wauki-Tocky. Let me see if I can... Oh, yeah, there you are. I watched as Timmy, strapped into a harness, stepped out of a tiny window into the air and balanced himself on a small length of pipe,
安全法规禁止我和他们一起走到脚手架上去。所以我只好回到下面，在巷子里对他们行注目礼。我们通过对讲机保持联系。让我看看我能不能……哦，对，你在那儿。我看着蒂米绑着安全带，从一个小窗户迈出步子走进空中，在一小段管子上平衡着身体，
about 45 meters above me. He drilled some. metal brackets into the wall, and then his father started handing him bamboo poles through the window, one by one. He laid them across the brackets, tied them up, and built a little platform for himself to stand on. The poles were light enough that he could just grab and hold them with one hand. Not exactly something you could do with steel. So every time when I receive the materials from the window, I have to treat the materials. Then my partner can fill it, and he'll release the materials from his hand.
在我上方大约45米处。他在墙上钻了一些金属支架，然后他父亲开始通过窗户把竹竿一根一根地递给他。他把竹竿横放在支架上，把它们捆好，为自己搭建了一个站立的小平台。竹竿足够轻，他单手就能抓握和拿稳。这绝对不是用钢材能做到的事。所以每次我从窗户接收材料时，我必须处理这些材料。然后我的搭档可以感觉到，他会松开手中的材料。
And if he cannot feel it, he shouldn't release the material. So that's how we communicate, and we never job anything. Within a few minutes, Timmy was already well on his way to making what some in the industry call a bird cage, a sort of safe enclosure for a repairman to work in. Later, Timmy would tell me this was a tougher job than he thought. Lots of unexpected angles and distances. But from where I was standing, you wouldn't know it. His father just kept handing him the bamboo poles at a steady rate.
如果他感觉不到，他就不应该松开材料。这就是我们沟通的方式，我们从不掉落任何东西。短短几分钟内，蒂米就已经在搭建行业内所谓“鸟笼”的道路上进展顺利了——这是一种供修理工在里面工作的安全围栏。后来，蒂米告诉我，这比他想象的要难。有许多意想不到的角度和距离。但从我站的地方看，你绝对看不出来。他父亲只是以稳定的频率不断地把竹竿递给他。
There's number six, and his father's already extending the seventh one while he's lashing the six into place. It probably takes no longer than ten seconds to connect them. There's some passers-by who were wondering what we're so fascinated by. As I watched Timmy and his father build out the birdcage, the alley can, continued to go about its business. Some cleaners came and went. An employee from one of the dim sum restaurants took out some trash. Another was moving around styrofoam boxes. And maybe that was the best part. The way the bamboo let everyone else's lives just go on. Steel scaffolding for this job would have likely had to start from the ground floor, blocking half of this narrow alley.
那是第六根，当他把第六根固定到位时，他父亲已经在递第七根了。连接它们大概只需要十秒钟左右。有一些路人在纳闷我们在着迷什么。当我看着蒂米和他的父亲搭起鸟笼时，小巷依旧在进行着它的日常。一些清洁工来来往往。点心茶楼的一名员工拿出了写垃圾。另一个人在挪动泡沫箱。而这或许是最好的部分。竹子让其他所有人的生活得以照常进行。这项工作的钢制脚手架可能不得不从底楼开始搭建，挡住这条狭窄小巷的一半。
But this scaffold never got anywhere near the ground. It stayed well out of the way of the hustle and bustle below. 90 minutes later, the cage was finished. Just another piece of bamboo scaffolding, floating above one of the city's busiest neighborhoods. Scenes like this are so commonplace that residents barely notice. But look up from nearly any street corner, and more likely than not, you can see bamboo scafflers making the nearly impossible look easy.
但这个脚手架从没有靠近过地面。它远远地避开了下方喧嚣的市井生活。90分钟后，鸟笼完工了。又一个竹脚手架，悬浮在城市最繁忙的社区之一上方。这样的场景太常见了，以至于居民们几乎注意不到。但从几乎任何一个街角抬头往上看，十有八九，你都能看到竹脚手架工人将几乎不可能完成的事变得轻而易举。
It's why bamboo still accounts for roughly 80% of all scaffolding in Hong Kong. But just because bamboo is easy to work with, doesn't mean it's easy to learn. That's bamboo's one honest disadvantage compared to metal. A bamboo master requires years of apprenticeship. The craft has been passed down father to son, job by job. I think it's the easiest way to explain is like a teacher. But in old days, when they learn from teacher, they live together.
这就是为什么竹子仍然占香港所有脚手架的大约80%。但仅仅因为竹子易于使用，并不意味着它容易学。这是竹子相比金属而言唯一实实在在的劣势。一个竹艺大师需要多年的学徒期。这门手艺由父及子，代代相传，通过一个个工作传承下来。我想最简单的解释方式就像是一位老师。但在过去的日子里，当他们向老师学习时，他们住在一起。
They even help to cook. They help to wash. So everything. Timmy told me he's a third-generation scaffolder. His family's company builds bamboo scaffolding all around town. He's also the assistant head of a builder's association. He said the work still challenges him, 12 years into the job, working together with his dad. And at work, I'll call him seafu.
他们甚至帮忙做饭。他们帮忙洗衣服。所以什么都做。蒂米告诉我他是第三代脚手架工人。他家族的公司在全城搭建竹脚手架。他还是建筑商协会的副会长。他说，入行12年，和父亲一起工作，这项工作依然在挑战着他。在工作时，我会叫他师傅。
Master. Master, yes. Are you a master already? Yes, I'm also a master. But on the Chinese mainland, where bamboo scaffolding was never as popular, this knowledge has almost entirely disappeared. It was mostly replaced by metal decades ago. And in 2022, it was banned nationwide for all housing and municipal engineering.
师傅。师傅，是的。你已经是师傅了吗？是的，我也是师傅。但在竹脚手架从未如此普及的中国内地，这种知识几乎已经完全消失了。几十年前，它在很大程度上被金属所取代。而在2022年，它在全国范围内被禁止用于所有房屋和市政工程。
Hong Kong is one of the last places on earth where bamboo scaffolding survives as a living practice, not as a heritage performance, but as the actual way buildings get built. But then came the fire, and the world watched as the towers in Tai Po burned, covered in bamboo. The search continues for survivors and those are horrifying pictures. And police say there are still people trapped inside the building. There are glimmers of torchlights and some floors. And the bamboo scalpelding on one of the 31-story tower blocks looks to have caught fire
香港是地球上最后几个竹脚手架作为活态传统得以幸存的地方之一，它不是作为非遗表演，而是作为建筑被建造的实际方式。但随后火灾发生了，全世界都看着大埔的楼宇在烈火中燃烧，上面覆盖着竹子。对幸存者和那些恐怖画面的搜寻仍在继续。警察说大楼内仍然有人被困。某些楼层有手电筒的微光闪烁。31层高楼之一上的竹脚手架似乎着火了，
and is causing the flames to spread. Being a Hong Konger, it's one of the most horrific things that I have ever. Words can't even describe it. we come back, the possible end of bamboo scaffolding and what it means for Hong Kong. We're back with reporter Julie Blisei. The same day I flew in from Beijing to cover the fire at one foot court, Timi So was called in for an emergency meeting at Hong Kong's Development Bureau. It had only been one day since the start of the fire.
并导致火势蔓延。作为一个香港人，这是我经历过的最恐怖的事情之一。言语甚至无法形容它。我们回来后，将探讨竹脚手架可能面临的终结及其对香港意味着什么。我们回到了记者朱莉·布吕塞身边。就在我从北京飞来报道宏福苑火灾的同一天，蒂米·索被紧急召集到香港发展局开会。距离火灾爆发才仅仅过去了一天。
And I was quite short that it comes so fast because the fire is not under control yet. It's just still at the second day of the fire, and it's a little bit shocked. A few months before, Hong Kong's government, under pressure from Beijing, had already begun making local construction companies increase their use of metal scaffolding. The government had cited safety concerns, although some suspected it was a way for Beijing to bring in more mainland construction workers who are trained on metal. So going into the meeting, Timmy was bracing him. And once I arrived the meeting place, there is an agenda on the table, and the agenda title is roadmap on adoption of scaffolding.
我感到十分震惊，因为事情来得太快了，火势当时还没有得到控制。那还是火灾的第二天，这让人有点震惊。几个月前，在来自北京的压力下，香港政府已经开始促使本地建筑公司增加金属脚手架的使用。政府曾以安全隐患为由，尽管有些人怀疑这是北京引入更多在金属脚手架方面受过培训的内地建筑工人的方式。因此在去开会的路上，蒂米一直在做心理准备。等我到达会场时，桌上有一份议程，议程的标题是“脚手架采用路线图”。
It was a timetable, drafted by the Development Bureau for the complete phase-out of bamboo scaffolding at all construction sites in Hong Kong. The official rationale was straightforward. Metal scaffolding is more fire-resistant than bamboo. The Bureau asked the Hong Kong construction industry to agree to the accelerated phase out of bamboo. It was time, they said, to move on. Timmy still spoke up. He resisted the ban, but only briefly. It was already clear that more than a hundred people had died in the fire.
这是一份由发展局起草的时间表，旨在全面淘汰香港所有建筑工地的竹脚手架。官方的理由很简单。金属脚手架比竹子更具防火性。发展局要求香港建筑行业同意加速淘汰竹子。他们说，是时候前行了。蒂米还是发了声。他抵制了禁令，但只是短暂地。当时已经很清楚，火灾中有一百多人丧生。
And so, he says, resistance felt both pointless and almost inappropriate. So everyone, they forgot how bamboo scaffolding builds Hong Kong And, yeah. At that time, I was very disappointed, very hopeless. Shortly after that, the phase-out was made public by the Hong Kong government. Bamboo scaffolding would be replaced with metal. Hong Kong's roughly 3,500 bamboo scaffolders would be incentivized to retrain to work with steel. But almost immediately, something unexpected happened.
因此，他说，反抗感觉既毫无意义，又近乎不合时宜。所以每个人，他们都忘记了竹脚手架是如何构筑香港的，而且，是的。当时，我感到非常失望，非常绝望。不久之后，香港政府公开了淘汰计划。竹脚手架将被金属取代。香港大约3500名竹脚手架工人将获得激励，重新接受培训以使用钢材。但几乎立刻，意想不到的事情发生了。
The public pushed back. People began posting videos online, trying and failing to set bamboo a light. Oh. The whole lot of people have a lot on-o-time do research. Bamboo has a very high ignition point of at least 260 degrees Celsius, and it is also very difficult to burn. No one was saying that the bamboo scaffolding hadn't caught fire, along with everything else in typo.
公众进行了反击。人们开始在网上发布视频，尝试点燃竹子却以失败告终。哦。大批人花了很多时间做研究。竹子的燃点非常高，至少在摄氏260度以上，而且它也非常难燃烧。没有人说大埔的竹脚手架没有着火，连同那里的一切一起。
It had. The question was whether the scaffolding was, what caused the fire to spread? Bamboos defender said no. The bamboo only burned after the flames had already spread. Not before. It wasn't the reason the fire got so bad. Instagram accounts ran posts claiming,
它确实着火了。问题在于，脚手架究竟是不是导致火势蔓延的原因？竹子的捍卫者说不是。竹子只有在火势已经蔓延之后才燃烧。而不是之前。它不是火势变得如此严重的原因。Instagram账号发布了声称以下内容的帖子：
Bamboo is innocent. And at a makeshift memorial that sprung up near the site of the fire, right next to notes expressing grief for the victims, I saw messages saying, don't blame the bamboo. This is actually one of the things that got me so interested in this story in the first place. Like, why did Hong Kongers rush to defend bamboo so fiercely?
竹子是无辜的。在火灾发生地点附近临时搭建的纪念碑旁，紧挨着表达对遇难者悲痛的便条，我看到了这样的留言：“不要怪竹子。”这其实是最初让我对这个故事如此感兴趣的原因之一。为什么香港人会急于如此激烈地捍卫竹子？
I put the question to Lowe, the Hong Kong engineer. I told him about Ma Meng, the man who defended the bamboo, even as the towers were still burning in front of us. People were so adamant about it. Like, no, it's not the bamboo. When the fire is even still happening. The bamboo is still burning at the same time. Why do the Hong Kong people care so much?
我把这个问题抛给了香港工程师罗。我向他提起马明——那个即使在大楼在他们面前燃烧时仍旧为竹子辩护的人。人们对此是如此坚决。就像，不，不是竹子。当时火灾甚至还在发生。竹子同时还在燃烧。为什么香港人这么在乎？
Why? Why people respond like that? Hmm. Oh, can I say the people you met, they're smart. They're smart. They're smart. Yeah, because we live with the bamboo for so many years, right? From our child age, we see everywhere as bamboo.
为什么？为什么人们会有这种反应？嗯。噢，我可以说你遇到的那些人，他们很聪明。他们很聪明。他们很聪明。是的，因为我们与竹子一起生活了这么多年，对吧？从我们的孩童时代起，我们看到到处都是竹子。
We love it. The tradition of bamboo scaffolding, that still means something to Hong Kongers. But also, they weren't just defending a construction material for the sake of convention. 168 people died in this fire and thousands lost their homes. People were sad and upset and low stress to me how eager he and others were to find out what really went wrong. But instead, it felt like the government was using bamboo as a scapegoat, a way to declare the case closed, instead of looking for the real culprit. Therefore, we angry about this and we realize that this is useless because the problem still is there. And a similar thing may be happening again, right?
我们热爱它。竹脚手架的传统对香港人来说仍然意味着某种东西。但同时，他们并不仅仅是为了传统的缘故而在捍卫一种建筑材料。这场火灾中有168人丧生，数千人失去家园。人们感到悲伤和沮丧，罗向我强调了他和其他人是多么渴望找出究竟出了什么问题。相反，感觉政府是在拿竹子当替罪羊，以此来宣布结案，而不是去寻找真正的罪魁祸首。因此，我们对此感到愤怒，并且我们意识到这是无济于事的，因为问题依然存在。类似的事情可能还会再次发生，对吧？
We didn't learn the lesson. But for many Hong Kongers, the bamboo ban also felt like part of a pattern that they'd come to recognize, one that began in 1997 when Hong Kong was handed back to China by the United Kingdom. Many residents worried about what would happen to their local democratic government under Chinese rule. So Beijing made a promise. One country, two systems. Yes, Hong Kong. would be part of China, but it would keep its own courts, civil liberties, and limited autonomy
我们没有吸取教训。但对于许多香港人来说，竹脚手架的禁令也让人觉得像是他们已经开始认出的某种模式的一部分，这种模式始于1997年香港由英国主权移交回中国。许多居民担心他们的本地民主政府在中国的统治下会发生什么。因此，北京做出了一个承诺。一国两制。是的，香港。将成为中国的一部分，但它将保留自己的法院、公民自由和有限的自治权
for 50 years. But one country, two systems didn't last long. Since 2021, Hong Kong's government has consisted only of what Beijing calls patriots, candidates approved by the central government. Today, it's widely understood that the city administrators will pretty much do Beijing's bidding. And increasingly, Hong Kongers suspect that what Beijing wants is to bring the city's cultural identity more in line with mainland China by taking away those things that have long made Hong Kong unique. For instance, Lowe told me how some historic buildings, buildings that reminded people of
长达50年。但一国两制并没有持续多久。自2021年以来，香港政府完全由北京所称的“爱国者”——即经中央政府批准的候选人——组成。如今，人们普遍认为，这座城市的行政长官基本上会听从北京的指令。而且越来越多的香港人怀疑，北京想要的是通过剥夺那些长期以来让香港变得独特的因素，使这座城市的文化认同与中国内地更加一致。例如，罗告诉我，近年来一些历史建筑，那些让人想起
the old Hong Kong, have gotten demolished in recent years instead of preserved. And the city's iconic neon signs, those dense overlapping cascades of Chinese characters that lit up Hong Kong streets for decades, Beijing had almost all of those taken down. Also, they said, for safety concerns. We don't know why, but it seems to us that those unique things of Hong Kong is being failed out, right? Just like the bamboo scaffold, seems to us that we are moving like a normal mainland city.
老香港的建筑，被拆毁了而不是被保护起来。还有这座城市标志性的霓虹灯招牌——那些密密麻麻重叠在一起、几十年来照亮香港街道的汉字瀑布，北京把几乎所有这些都拆除了。同样，他们说，是出于安全考虑。我们不知道原因，但在我们看来，香港那些独特的东西正在被淘汰，对吧？就像竹脚手架一样，在我们看来，我们正变得像一个普通的内地城市。
Or, I don't know, this is just a feeling. But just saying these things outright, at least in public, has become too risky for most people. The national security law, which passed in 2020, has made any government criticism a potential crime. After the fire, one 24-year-old student was arrested for calling for an independent investigation. A political commentator in his 70s was arrested for criticizing the government's response online. The result is that most people in Hong Kong err on the side of keeping their thoughts private,
或者，我不知道，这只是一种感觉。但直言不讳地表达这些事情，至少在公开场合，对大多数人来说已经变得太危险了。2020年通过的《国家安全法》使得任何对政府的批评都可能成为潜在的罪行。火灾发生后，一名24岁的学生因呼吁独立调查而被捕。一位70多岁的政治评论员因在网上批评政府的应对措施而被捕。结果是，香港的大多数人都倾向于将他们的想法藏在心里，
or at least anonymous. Lowe, for example, maintains an Instagram account he uses to say, what he really thinks about the building industry in Hong Kong. He keeps it under a pseudonym. And if I need to speech freely, then it would be sensitive. Yeah, yeah, it would be sensitive. At this point, Lowe dropped his voice.
或者至少保持匿名。例如，罗就维护了一个Instagram账号，用来表达他对香港建筑行业的真实想法。他使用的是化名。如果我需要自由发言，那么这就会很敏感。是的，是的，这会很敏感。说到这里，罗降低了声音。
This kind of speech, he whispered to me, it's very dangerous in Hong Kong. But seems that the government is not working for us. They're working for Beijing. But at least so far, even if they're not allowed to criticize the government or blame it for the fire, Hong Kongers have not yet been punished for simply defending bamboo scaffolding, which means these days the discussion of bamboo can also function as a kind of coded form of political speech, a way of saying things that can't be said out loud.
这种言论，他向我耳语道，在香港非常危险。但看起来政府不是在为我们工作。他们是在为北京工作。但至少到目前为止，即使他们不被允许批评政府或将其归咎于火灾，香港人目前还没有因为仅仅捍卫竹脚手架而受到惩罚，这意味着如今对竹子的讨论也可以发挥一种隐蔽的政治言论的作用，成为一种表达无法大声说出来的事情的方式。
Five days after the fire started, I came across this group of young people, who were filming a music video. The 26-year-old rapper named Chen Gip K, dressed head-to-toe in black, rapping directly into the camera. Turned out, turned out, Chen's song was about bamboo. Bamboo is my name,
火灾发生五天后，我遇到了这群正在拍摄音乐录影带的年轻人。这位26岁、名叫陈吉K（Chen Gip K）的说唱歌手，从头到脚一身黑衣，对着镜头直接说唱。原来，原来陈的这首歌是关于竹子的。竹子是我的名字，
stubborn by nature, it goes. Bamboo is my name, stronger than you think. The week before, shortly after the fire broke out, Chan had rushed to Tai Po to help out. He delivered water and food to the firefighters. And now, he said, he wanted to use his music to help the bamboo as well. Because of the fires, we all realized that some people blame the bamboo.
天生顽强，歌词唱道。竹子是我的名字，比你想象的更强大。前一周，火灾刚爆发不久，陈就冲到大埔去帮忙。他给消防员送水和食物。现在，他说，他也想用他的音乐来帮助竹子。因为火灾，我们都意识到有些人把责任归咎于竹子。
Yeah. So I make this song happen. Because I think we all know it's not. because of the bamboo. It's just about some... I can't say too much, you know, because of the law. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。所以我创作了这首歌。因为我认为我们都知道那不是因为竹子。这只是关于一些……我不能说太多，你知道的，因为法律的原因。是的。是的。
Yes. Oh, that's fine. That's fine. Can I quote you saying, I can't say too much because of the law? Or I don't know. Yes, you can. Yeah? I think, yes.
是的。哦，没关系。没关系。我可以引用你说“我不能说太多，因为法律的原因”吗？还是我不知道。可以的，你可以。是吗？我想，可以。
Okay. I think yes. Chen was recording the music video at the edge of Hong Kong in the village of Sautau. The village was holding a festival that only happens every 10 years. For the festival, they build a temporary bamboo theater, 6,000 seats, Cantonese opera, ceremonies that last for days. It stands for a few weeks, then it comes down. When Julie visited, it was still under construction.
好吧。我想可以。陈是在香港边缘的沙头角村（Sautau）拍摄这支音乐录影带的。村里正在举行一个十年才办一次的节日。为了这个节日，他们搭建了一个临时的竹戏剧场，拥有6000个座位，上演粤剧，举办持续数天的仪式。它会矗立几周，然后拆除。朱莉去参观时，它还在建设中。
It was extraordinary, just this vast bamboo skeleton completely open to the sky. You could walk through it through these corridors of bamboo poles, the size of a huge circus tent, about 30 meters tall. And at some point I just laid on the ground just looking up at the structure, at this intricate web of bamboo extending upwards. I asked one of the festival's organizers, if bamboo is banned, can this festival still happen? Can the theater still be built in 10 years or 20? He didn't have a certain answer. But he did say, I can't imagine building this out of metal.
这太非凡了，这片巨大的竹子骨架完全向天空敞开。你可以穿过它，走过这些由竹竿组成的走廊，它有巨大的马戏团帐篷那么大，大约30米高。在某个时刻，我只是躺在地上，抬头看着这个结构，看着这个向高处延伸的错综复杂的竹网。我问其中一位节日组织者，如果竹子被禁了，这个节日还能办下去吗？10年或20年后还能搭起这个剧场吗？他没有给出确切的答案。但他确实说过，我无法想象用金属来搭建这个。
Bamboo Master Timiso is 38 years old. He assumed he still had decades of work ahead of him. and a craft to pass on. Now he's not sure. When asked about the resistance campaign, how people rose up in defense of bamboo, he can only manage the weakest of smiles. The local training center has already canceled classes
竹艺大师蒂米·索今年38岁。他原本以为自己前方还有数十年的工作要做。还有一门手艺要传下去。现在他不敢确定了。当被问及反抗运动、人们如何奋起捍卫竹子时，他只能勉强挤出一个最无力的微笑。当地的培训中心已经取消了新竹脚手架工人所需的课程。
required for new bamboo scafflers. And the government is also providing incentives for all 3,500 existing bamboo workers to switch licenses and get one for working with metal scaffolding. The aim is to replace bamboo completely with metal at all major construction sites within two years. So there will be no more
政府还在为所有3500名现有的竹脚手架工人提供奖励，让他们转换执照，获得金属脚手架的操作证。其目的是在两年内在所有主要建筑工地上用金属完全取代竹子。所以将不会再有
new bamboo scaffolders. So I think it's a little bit too late, but at least someone noticed us. It's been over half a year since the fire, and no one is blaming the bamboo scaffolding anymore, including the Hong Kong government. Instead, investigations have zeroed in on other highly flammable construction materials,
新的竹脚手架工人了。所以我觉得有点太晚了，但至少有人注意到了我们。火灾发生已经半年多了，没有人再责怪竹脚手架了，包括香港政府。相反，调查已经锁定在其他高度易燃的建筑材料上，
the styrofoam boards that covered the windows, and the netting that surrounded the scaffolding, just like Ma'amang said on day one of the fire. No safety checks had ever identified or flagged the use of these flammable materials, even though residents explicitly complained about them to authorities. Seven people have been charged following the fire. All of them involved with the companies that carried out the renovations. But no one from the Hong Kong government has been held accountable. And even if the bamboo isn't to blame,
覆盖窗户的泡沫板，以及环绕脚手架的网子，就像马明在火灾第一天所说的那样。没有任何安全检查曾识别或标记过这些易燃材料的使用，尽管居民曾明确向当局投诉过它们。火灾发生后已有七人被控。他们全都与进行翻新工程的公司有关。但香港政府中没有人被追究责任。而且即使竹子不是罪魁祸首，
the phase out of bamboo scaffolding won't be wrong. reversed. Like Timmy said, the new policy is moving forward. Still, Timmy doesn't think bamboo scaffolding can ever be banned completely, so long as there's an air-conditioning unit and a hard-to-reach spot in a narrow alley between two oddly shaped buildings, 65 stories up. After I left Hong Kong, Chan sent me the demo of the song he'd been singing at the bamboo theater. I listened to the lyrics again. I won't accept this bullshit, they go.
淘汰竹脚手架的做法也不会被撤销。正如蒂米所说，新政策正在向前推进。不过，蒂米并不认为竹脚手架会被完全禁止，只要在两个形状怪异的建筑之间狭窄小巷里、在65层高处还有一个难以触及的空调机组。我离开香港后，陈把他在竹戏剧场唱的那首歌的Demo发给了我。我又听了一遍歌词。我不会接受这种胡说八道，歌词唱道。
24 hours engulfed in fire, and still I won't break. Why put the blame on me? One day, you'll miss me when I'm gone. One day you will miss me when I'm gone. To get a strong. Like bamboo. Just chute chong like bamboo. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Julie Blu-Sea and edited by Joe Rosenberg
被烈火吞噬24小时，而我依然不会折断。为什么要怪我？有一天，当我离去时，你会想念我的。有一天你会想念我的，当我离去时。变得坚强。像竹子一样。就像竹子一样直冲云霄。本周的“99%隐形”由朱莉·布吕塞报道，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）剪辑，
with additional production by Jason DeLeon, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and George Langford. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Many thanks to Raphaela Andritzi, an architect and photographer in Hong Kong who helped us tremendously with the research for this episode and introduce us to Bamboo Masters, Timi Soe and his father. Rafael has been documenting Hong Kong's bamboo scaffolds since 2020. Her writing and photography will be featured in an upcoming book that looks very cool. It's called The Bamboo Metropolis, and we will have a link to it on our website. Kathy Two is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director.
由杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）参与制作，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）和乔治·兰格福德（George Langford）创作。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Hesha）完成。非常感谢拉斐拉·安德里齐（Raphaela Andritzi），她是一位在香港的建筑师兼摄影师，在这一集的调研中给予了我们极大的帮助，并将我们引见给了竹艺大师蒂米·索和他的父亲。拉斐拉自2020年以来一直在记录香港的竹脚手架。她的文字和摄影作品将收录在一本即将出版、看起来非常酷的书里。这本书名为《竹之大都会》（The Bamboo Metropolis），我们将在官网上提供它的链接。凯茜·图（Kathy Two）是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔stad（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监。
Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lodge Madonna, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallin and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora Building, and beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝伊（Chris Barubei）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、洛奇·麦当娜（Lodge Madonna）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、塔林和雷恩·斯特勒德利（Rain Stradley），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。“99%隐形”的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是天狼星XM（Series XM）播客家族的一部分，总部目前位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区潘多拉大楼（Pandora Building）以北六个街区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。有关该服务器的链接以及“99PI”的每一集往期节目，都可以在99PI.org上找到。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。